let's get the show on the road 2021
sergey nov
okay so
let's actually go
e5 this time we haven't actually played
e5 that often funnily enough even though
it's probably the move that most people
in the chat play and we we're facing ry
lopez
and i'm thinking
we'll go for the main line
um i'm thinking we'll go for the main
line which is of course a6
bishop a4 and knight f6
[Music]
yeah this is this was first played by
paul morphy
and since become the main line thank you
alice cpu
all right so
what is the what is the main move here
so there's an interesting
there's an interesting distinction to be
made so it's not bishop c5 bishop c5
is called
the archangel
b5 and bishop c5 the main move is bishop
to e7 just modestly developing the
bishop
to e7
and i'll talk a little bit after the
game about some of the
the possible lines here and when i say
mainline i don't necessarily mean it's
the best line it's just the most popular
variation
and at this point the move rookie one
actually poses a threat
now you'll notice that
at various points in the rye lopez white
can take the knight and take the pawn
here it doesn't make much sense because
the pawn on e4 is hanging
but once he plays rookie one bishop
takes c6 and knight takes c5 actually
becomes a threat
so you might think well then it's time
to play d6 but before d6 we throw in a
move which is very very helpful we start
by playing b5 grabbing space on the
queen side forcing the bishop back and
now generally speaking we play d6
but we don't have to play d6 anymore
because no pawn 95 is no longer hanging
the main move is still d6 not in order
to defend the pawn but in order to open
up the bishop but we can also play the
marshall gambit which is
castles
not moving the d-pawn and hoping to play
d5 in one fell swoop
so let's try
i want to play the marshall let's castle
and if y plays c3 here then we have a
choice of playing the marshall with d5
or transposing back into the main line
with d6
and he plays c3
let's go with the marshall gamut d5
now i'm sure most people in the chat
have probably seen this before um it's a
very common guess at the highest level
and of course the gambit is because we
sacrificed upon e5
i take c5 rook take c5
all right so our knight is hanging who
knows what the main move for black is
here
we need to do something about the threat
of capturing the knight now if you don't
know this it's a little bit hard to
figure out why the best move is what it
is and i can talk a little bit about
that after the game the best move here
is to defend the knight with a pawn c6
defending the knight with a pawn
generally defending a piece with a pawn
is going to be the best way forward
now we need to get the stroke off of e5
it's really in our way we need to create
chances against white's king
and in order to do that we need to how
do we chase the rook away
well we need to do it knowing that once
the rook moves our pieces need to be
aimed at the white king so moves bishop
d6
and
we go queen h4
bringing the queen into the attack
sinking it into h3 this is all theory
and at this point i myself am not a huge
marshall specialist i i'm rusty on the
theory but we'll figure it out
and it looks like white might be out of
book as well
given that he's taking
a good chunk of time here
now it's very clear where our
compensation
derives from we've got i would say an
advantage in development
and white's got swiss cheese
light squares on the king side
particularly given that this bishop
would love to be on g2 here if this
bishop were on g2 black would have no
compensation
but given that the bishop is not on g2
and there's no way of getting there
white is going to have to deal with the
long-term weakness of his
weak light
squares and so
the immediate threat is bishop to g4
attacking attacking the queen and trying
to sink it into f3 for a lobster pins
are made eventually
yeah marshall lost to capoblanca so
frank james marshall who was the first
to play the marshall
uh the game where he played it for the
first time he did i believe lose to
capablanca but
you know that doesn't mean the line is
bad and that doesn't mean it it
shouldn't bear his name knight d2 is not
to my knowledge one of the the main
lines
that's a
it's a sensible move i mean he develops
the knight but it's a bit awkward i mean
now the bishop can't move
and he doesn't do anything against uh
against the possibility of developing
the bishop to g4 so
my question why not let's let's play
bishop g4 see where his queen okay
f3 in such positions is tremendously
weakening
and there's a super typical tactic that
oftentimes stems from from this weakness
and i'm sure everybody's familiar with
it
what am i talking about
and the moment f3 is played you should
start thinking about this this is this
is a pattern that you should you know
hammer into your head
well it's not knight e3 folks because
that blunders the knight it's bishop
takes g3
so the move f3 it weakens the pawn on g3
that's a weak link in white's position
and sacking the bishop on g3 is often a
very low risk venture why is it low risk
aren't we sacking the bishop well
because we have perpetual check in our
pocket once he takes the bishop
at the very least we have perpetual
check in our pocket and remember that if
you're evaluating a sacrifice and you're
trying to win the game but you spot a
perpetual that's still very valuable
because
if you've spotted at least a draw then
you know the sacrifice becomes very low
risk and you can spend essentially the
rest of your time trying to find a win
if you don't find it okay of course you
want it to win
but still a draw is better than a loss
so don't
don't discount um
ideas like that where you have a
guaranteed draw because
i can really lower the risk of going for
something that otherwise would be super
super risky
um
so what happens here well if he takes
the light squared bishop then he gets
checkmated queen h2 king f1 queen f2
so essentially
kind of has to take this bishop i guess
technically rookie 2 should be
considered by white maybe rookie 2 is in
fact
the best move i don't know
but we'll cross that bridge if he plays
it
and if he takes this bishop then we play
queen takes g3
everybody can see the the perpetual we
have but i believe that we have more
than just a perpetual
if he goes for this and i think it's
actually quite straightforward
um
the attacking method is quite
straightforward
so start thinking about what we're going
to do in the event of take stakes in
king h1
how are we going to create
threats that are better than just a
perpetual
okay he keeps disconnecting that f1 is
played
that's not a very testing move
um
and one of the big mistakes people make
when they're sacrificing and attacking
is forgetting that we can just win
material in certain cases so
here you might be thinking about bishop
takes f3 well then queen takes f3 and we
have nothing
bishop takes h2 knight takes h2 nothing
there but wait a minute the rook is just
hangs we just take the rook and we're up
in exchange and the attack continues so
black is winning here
relatively straightforward attack
after f6g4 some work is still required
though it's not it's not entirely over
and
if he takes this bishop then we can play
bishop takes
f3
yeah the marshall is very dangerous if
white doesn't know the theory
the move was knight f4 in the other line
yes knight f4 on the other line was was
winning
one interesting thing about the marshall
is that at the highest level it often
leads to a drop because if white knows
theory
then in most lines uh the majority of
lines actually go into an endgame where
black needs to be a little bit careful
to make a draw
but at lower levels
uh the marshall is often played as a
winning line in order to play for a win
because if you don't know the theory
then as i said you get
you know you're liable to get attacked
right so
what should we do here well we can move
our bishop back to h4 but that's a
little bit too plain vanilla
can we squeeze more out of the situation
yes we can we can play rook a to e8
defend the bishop
and simultaneously bring the rook into
the game
all right and where can this root go
well it can go up to e4 in order to
attack g4 that could be simply a
crushing idea
uh it doesn't matter rook a8 recap v8
the only reason i put the a rook on e8
um is because i thought potentially i
could play f5
and try to open up the file that's
literally the only thing that entered my
mind otherwise i don't think it really
matters
i thought that i might push this f pawn
out and if he trades then this other
rook might get into the game
bishop f4
well the move f5 i mentioned is quite
quite a good idea here but
i don't see a reason not to stick with
our original plan
and
play what move
i mean f5 actually does look really
really nice here
yeah
rookie four is great
actually you know what let's play f5
because
if we can open up the f file the win is
going to come a lot faster if we play
rookie four
our opponent plays bishop back to g3
we trade the bishops then we take the
pawn on g4 and we're up another pawn but
it's going to take a while for us to to
translate that into into mate
let's let's play f5
let's at least try to get the g5 the
file open he's probably going to go g5
which would be correct but then we have
a passed pawn on f5 which could later
push out to f4 and accelerate the pace
of of the attack
um
as i often as i often say in such
positions it's less about
you know the specific moves that you
play because there's gonna be a lot of
stuff that wins the game
um as long as you're following a pretty
consistent strategy and you're making
you know healthy straightforward
attacking moves you'll be fine but
should be five is a good move
um intercepting the rook so now our
bishop hangs uh just a visiting family
and um we need to move the bishop at
this point so now it's time for bishop
h4
this bishop is not not an issue though
if we can open up the file the game ends
quickly
i think you'll hash me with the 16
months and let's take the rook
now the f file is ours
and there's a million threats rook f2 or
cafe g5
queen e2
um
what do we do
well rook g5 knight g3
or rg5 king h1
so i would either double up the rooks
go rook f8
um or i would go with the immediate rook
f2 attacking the queen and threatening
checkmate on g2
the only issue with rook f2 is that he
can take that rogue
and at the end of the day he's gonna
have two pieces for the queen that might
last a little bit longer
so if we want to play for a maximum if
we really want to finish the game as
quickly as possible rook e to f8 might
be more sensible
but then he might play bishop drops back
to g3
so i don't particularly like this
approach of trying to find a way to win
fastest if you're if you see a move that
wins the queen and you know for a fact
that you know how to win the resulting
position just do it
um don't be lazy and try to find you
know it's good to try to find the
fastest win but there's also a limit to
that and
i think you can get in trouble when you
try when you rule out options just
because you feel like they'll take a
long time to win
all right
okay so
let's throw in another rook check just
to reposition the rook onto an open file
and now here's the best approach
how is white going to defend
against a potential rook lift to g5 what
move do we want to eliminate what
defensive resource do we want to somehow
eliminate
we want to eliminate
the possibility of white blocking a
potential check with the knight of the
bishop how can we do that
can we take that square under control
we absolutely can we can push the h-bond
out first h4
white is totally paralyzed it's not like
he can do anything and then we follow up
with a rook left to g5 and force the
king out into the open typical idea
taking a square under okay well rook d1
classic mistake here would be just
automatically go h4 but you have to keep
your eyes peeled for faster alternatives
like queen g4 that would win the rook
pretty simple game
um and at this level the marshall is a
very good weapon against the main line
real lopez
so
just really quickly rookie one
v5 so we're not going to talk at length
about the first part of the game just
because you know i could talk about the
ray lopez for ages
but it's this is not really an opening
course
um
now the thing is at the highest level
people don't really go into the marshall
all that much anymore
if you watch um people like wesley and
duda and geary
they uh they play what's called the
anti-martial so
at the highest level the marshal is
considered to essentially equalize for
black nobody's found
a serious anything serious for white in
the martial
so what you'll often see
is people playing a4 in this position
which gets sort of a different kind of
position than
you can't play d5 here i mean you just
blunt or b5
and after b4
oftentimes white goes for example d4 and
this this gets its own type of position
again you're not permitting black to
play d5 and enter the marshall thing
because i've been labeled and he's
madera
if that makes sense
but even 10 years ago almost everybody
went into the marshall
so
and people still do it's not like
it's not like people don't go into it
marshall was actually the second guy to
play it
and originally marshall's idea was not
to take on d5 of the night
against uh a guy named freer in 1917 and
then against capoblanca now against
capoblanca he played differently
in his very first game in the marshall
in a simul
he played e4 here which still remains
uh the second most popular move
but
according to modern day theory this is
not just just not good for black
d c6
ef3
and white could even grab this other
pawn
and it turns out that despite black's
initiative
if i remember correctly there is just
not enough compensation for the two
pawns in a position like this
so in 1918 one year later marshall kind
of realized that and he went for knight
takes d5
but back then the theory of the marshal
was not very well developed
uh so after 95 95 rookie five
marshall originally as well as everybody
else up until the 1940s played knight f6
originally everybody played knight f6
nowadays this is not considered a very
good move and the idea is to reinvolve
the knight via g4
and the move c6 was only played with the
first time
in 1939 by
chod alexander who also worked on
um i think
decrypting german communication during
world war ii interestingly he was also
the first person to play c6
in the marshall thank you love that guy
for the five
damn girl
damn girl
okay you should watch um
what's that movie with touring
what's that movie with turing that has
chod alexander in it
all right um
so c6
imitation game d4 bishop d6 or key one
queen h4 g3 queen h3
and here there are
um there are two main moves
there are two main moves
one of them is bishop e3 and the other
one is rook e4 knight t2 is just bad
this move
is one line trying to get to h4 and get
rid of the queen
the other line is to get the bishop out
first
to e3
and if black plays bishop g4 here
then white's queen can swing up to d3
with the idea of bishop f3 queen f1 and
white is safe
so there's a tremendous amount of theory
here but nobody has really proven
an advantage for white and and currently
black is doing great in the marshall
absolutely did not refute it um it's
just that marshall didn't play
accurately because the theory was not
well developed
so knight d2 is a essentially fatal
mistake because of bishop g4
perhaps white should have moved the
queen to c2 but now rook a8 just wins
and look at this position black simply
overwhelms white in the center and on
the king's side
and if white plays knight f3
then this is a very very nasty pin that
we can follow up on with queen h5
in g2 rookie 8 white's position is in
ruins
so this move knight d2 is a huge mistake
f3 bishop g3
and had white taken on g3
after queen g3 king h1
i do believe that the winning move is
knight f4 bringing the knight into the
attack threatening checkmate on g2
if he defends this way then we have mate
if he tries to give up the rook
to get rid of the knight then we play
bishop takes f3
i think that's the simplest
takes takes then we take the rook
and we have a massive
attack on top of the material advantage
so
the engine is indicating that the only
defensive option here
really is to play rookie 2 and try to
give up the exchange but avoid the
immediate
consequences of the attack
bishop takes c2 queen e2
and of course black is much much better
white doesn't have enough for the piece
but
rookie e8 queen f1
and y can try to survive this
um
all right so bishop g4 f3 bishop g3
knight f1 takes takes 4k e8 and the game
is over
yeah takes takes ship f4 and f5 trying
to open the f file
if fight had gone g5 i was thinking now
we could go rookie four
and then push the f pawn once the bishop
moves thank you itchy badger for the uh
for the three months i appreciate it
all right
yeah
so that's that's that that was a pretty
uneventful game any questions about it
any questions about this game or the
marshall i've only had a couple of games
i played the marshall in one classical
game with black
and drew i drew dingle around on the
white side of the marshall but i kind of
played
i didn't even really test him
was in a protest league
how is h3 instead of c3 to counter the
marshall yeah white has several ways to
play the nc marshall yancey marshall is
not just one thing it's several moves
that
discourage black from playing d5 one of
them is h3
and i believe d5 here is not accurate
because after ed5 knight t5 white does
not have to take e5 i think after a4
white is supposed to be better here
because the c3 square is left open for
the knight that's the key idea that's
the key difference yeah so after h3
black kind of i think has to revert to
one of the main lines either d6 or
bishop v7
but i don't know you'll have to check
that
on your own i'm not too much too much of
a specialist
[Music]
you